It's been a hundred years since the Spanish Flu, and now, we have COVID-19.
So, will pandemics, diseases that affect nearly every country on Earth, be the new normal?
We live in a cleaner environment, which does not allow pathogens to thrive.
On the other hand, because we are encroaching into new environments,...
...we are opening ourselves to unknown pathogens.
Many scientists and analysts argue that over the last 30 years,...
...humans have created the ideal conditions to make a small outbreak of a virus go global.
It's almost like we've made the perfect storm.
What are the reasons?
Well, we've been travelling more, often moving countries whether by choice or not,...
...and we're sending stuff all around the world too:...
...food, animals, plants, gifts.
Cities and towns are becoming more populated with people living closer together,...
...and we've been clearing land to build more homes,...
...losing forests which are often the source of new medicines and cures.
So, does this mean scientists can tell us when the next pandemic will be?
Well, no.
No one was able to predict the SARS-CoV-2 pandemic...
...because we didn't even know that this virus existed.
Scientists have been saying we need to set up systems to prepare for such eventualities.
Viruses will keep appearing.
The challenge now is for governments to contain any virus that comes into their country...
...and for people to change their habits to reduce the likelihood of disease spreading...
...to stop a pandemic like COVID-19 happening again.